はい それではよろしくお願いします
これからこの感覚器官を悟るというテーマでお話しさせていただきます
で あの感覚器官が悟るということより
それで皆様あまり気づかない問題がございますので
そこからアクセスしたいと思います
で テーマとして この知りたい
知りたい 知りたいと でしょうね
誰でも まあ生命たるものはね
知りたいというすごい希望が持ってるんです
この皆様方は知りたいと思ったら
いろいろ勉強したい 知らないものを知りたいという
なんかかっこつけたことを思っているかもしれませんだけど
ミミズでも知りたいという気持ちはあるんですよ
基本的に知りたいっていうのは
自分の肉体を維持するために
死なないために 知らなきゃ生きていられません
だからカラスはカラスなりに知ってるし
ミミズはミミズなりに知ってます
ゴキブリはゴキブリなりに必要なことは知ってます
それ知らなかったらもうやられちゃいますよ
ミミズでもなんか偉そうなこと上に上がっちゃうとね
鳥に取られて食べられちゃうし
ゴキブリでも平気でもうみんないるところに出てきたら
もう殺されちゃうしね
だからこの知りたい範囲はちょこっと間違っちゃうと大変なことになるんです
ですから 我々人間も知りたい知りたいと思っているのは
だいたいゴキブリ程度ですよ
失礼ですかね そう言われると
これは失礼じゃなくて本当なんです
で ただ 自分の命を守るために必要な情報を得るだけ
ゴキブリ程度だと言ったら
どうせ機嫌が悪くなるでしょ
だって我々はね 物理学知ってるわ
科学知ってるわ 宇宙船も作ってるわね
コンピューターパソコンも作ってるわ
ゴキブリって違うんじゃないかなと
何言ってるのかと 違います
そういうものも結局は生きるために
収入を得るために やってるんじゃないんですかね
なんで宇宙船やらいろいろ開発してるんですかね
科学者たちは それで彼らにとっては収入が入る
仕事がある また いいことをやったぞという充実感
満足感がある すべて栄養なんですよ
それでなきゃやりませんよ
皆様 学校に行ってなんで勉強したんですかね？なんで大学で勉強したんですかね
何か仕事を見つけるためでしょ
だからゴキブリと同じです
命を守るために必要だから知りたいんですよ
だからかわいそうなことはゴキブリ学校はありませんね
ゴキブリは環境を知るために学校には行かない
ほんの少々の知識で生きていられます
私たちだったら 学校にもどこにも行けなかったら生きていられません
もう食べるものはなくなっちゃうんです
死んじゃうんです だから
学校から大学まで 研究所やらありとあらゆる知識世界があるんですよ
これは人間はダメか下手かね
まあどちらかわかりませんだけどね
学校まで行って学ばなくちゃいけないかわいそうな生命ですよ
ですから知りたいということは
どんな生命にもある ものすごく必要な欲望なんです
だからそれから喋らなくちゃいけないんです
これから人間のことを喋りますけど
人といえば何でも知りたがる
それもおかしいでしょうに
何でも知りたがらなくてもいいでしょうに
まあ自分の命をね 幸福で幸せで
安全 安全して 安心して生きていられるぐらいの知識でいいんでしょうに
でもなんかわからないんだけど
なんかまあ余計なことまで知りたくなるんですよ
必要であろうと どうでもいいことであろうと知りたいんですよ
それ考えてください ゴキブリは冷蔵庫の裏でいれば大丈夫でしょ
あるいは台所にやっても
いろいろ品物を荷物を入れている中で隠れていれば
夜上に上がってきて 何か食べてまた隠れればいいでしょうね
いえ もっと世界を知りたいと思って
今に入ったらどうなるんですかね
余計なことを知ろうとすると
奥さんの総理がね これ人間にも来るんですよ
余計なことを知りたくなると命がなくなるんですよ
知って得するものはある
当然ね それは不思議なものではなく
ただ生きるために役に立つものです
不思議なものを知って得するわけじゃないんです
野菜の料理どうしましょうかとかね
じゃがいもの皮をむく
新しい方法はないんでしょうかとかね
より早く栗の皮をむくためには
すごくね 爪も痛くなるしね
指も汚れちゃうし なんとかいい方法ないのかとかね
そういう知識で十分ですけど
それでは得しますよ 知って損することもあります
これは冗談っぽく書いたんですけどね
余計なものを知ると 例えば FBI やら CIA やらね
そういう組織に殺されますよ
あるいはマフィアとかね
余計なことを知っちゃうと
もう命がないということになるんです
だから 必要なこと以外は知らない方がいいと思いますよ
でも少々待ちと 本当でしょうかと
で 知って損するというテーマについていきます
知らなくても良いことを知って悩んだり苦しんだりする場合もあります
殺されるということはありえないと思うかもしれませんだけど
でも我々はね 余計なことを知って
殺されなくてもかなり激しく悩む場合ありますよ
これは殺されるよりはきついと思いますけど
だってずっと悩まなくちゃいけないんだからね
怒ったり憎んだりする場合もあります
例えば 誰かさんのなんとかなんとか聞いたところで
ずっとそれに対して怒って
あるいはその人を憎んだり
だから怒ったり憎んだりになっちゃうと
もうきりがなく もう次から次へ
もう死ぬまでやるんでしょうね
だから余計なことを知ると
そういう大変なことになるんです
例えば噂話 それ一つの例なんですね
噂話はいかがでしょうかと
噂話するっていうことは
自分が知らないことを聞くことでしょ
知らないことを知ることになるんです
それって幸せになりますかと
噂というのは 他人の悪口をその本人がいないところで言うふらすことです
皆様 噂いっぱいやるんだけど
定義知らないでしょ 噂話
話っていうのは他人の悪口を言うんです
その人いないところで
他人の良いことをいないところで言うのは噂ではありません
それはすごい立派なことです
これはテレビでもマスコミでもどこでもやっている
我々学校に行ったら いろんな人の自伝とか読んでるでしょ
あるいは誰か書いたものに
何々さんがどうやったのかとかね
それはその人の噂 悪口じゃないでしょ
それはほんまで出すんだから
噂話じゃないんです だから人の良いところはいないところで勉強するのは噂話ではありません
噂っていうのは悪いところを言うんですよ
その人がいないところで
その人に知られないようにして
でもどうなるかというと
これは結構心汚しますよ
自分がすっごくだらしない
性格の悪い人の穴ばっかしに
見る 穴探し屋になるんですよね
穴探し屋とか汚物探し屋なんですよ
人のこと知ったら何か汚物ないのかと
そればっかり探すものすごい性格的に嫌な人間になるんですよ
だから本人にしたっても
知れば知るほど気持ち悪い
あの人はあんな格好をしているんだけど
本当はこういう人だよとかね
あの人はよく人気あるんだけど
実はそういう人だよとかね
そうすると自分の心で気持ち悪いんでしょうね
結局は そこで噂の相手が知ったら大変なことになるでしょうに
大変なことになる 時々もう裁判かけられる時もありますよ
相手も怒る こちらは悩む
相手にバレたら自分の悪口言ってるんだろと言ったら
相手はカンカン怒るんです
それでバレたところ 瞬間からこちらがもう悩んで悩んで悩んでキリがないんです
その上 時間の無駄遣いといえば大変なそう
噂話をするということは
何の役にも立たない時間の無駄なんですよ
ですから 料理する暇がなくて
チンするものしか買えなくなっちゃうし
あるいは外でご飯食べる羽目になっちゃうし
それで体に悪いものばっかり食べちゃって
もっと安くね あの手作り料理だったらもうかなり安く出来上がりますけどね
体にもよろしいし こんな時間無駄になっちゃって
大変なことになります
それは女性の場合でも男性の場合でも
噂話ばっかりやっちゃって
仕事をする時間がなくなっちゃうんですね
それでものすごい恥かけられる羽目になりますよ
能力はないんだとか 怠け者やとかね
あれやこれやと言われちゃって
競争に負けて惨めで生きていることになるんですね
そういうすべてのことは
あの噂という無駄なことを知るという世界から生まれるんですね
これ 一つの例ですよ まだいっぱいありますけどね
精神力の浪費にもなって疲れます
そこで余計なことを知れば知るほど精神的に疲れるんですよ
栗の皮のむき方 ものすごく新しい裏技あるんだそうと知ったら疲れません
あるいは 何でしたっけ？カボチャをね
カボチャにするともう1時間ぐらいかかるんだそうと
これはね 15分でできますよ
方法あるんだよと 誰かに教えてもらっちゃうと疲れませんよ
これちゃんとメモを書いておいて
自分でやってみて ああ
よかったと 私に聞かないでください
どういう方法かと まあチンすることでしょうね
おそらく はい 次のテーマ
今終わったのは 知ることっていうのは本能的に必要なもの
それは生きるためにということをよく覚えてほしい
食べるためにということ
学校も大学も研究所も全部
だから決して研究所で世界的な一流の研究者だからといって
うちにいる あのもう高校で卒業している自分の母親より優れているわけじゃないんです
同じ知識なんです 母親はしっかり家庭を守って息子を育てちゃったんだからね
必要な知識あったんです
それで息子がなんとかなんとか研究して科学者になって
すごい世界一流の研究所の所長になっているんだと
それはその人 給料もらうためにやっているだけのことで
それで家族を養っているでしょう
だから大したことないんです
誰の知識も上下ないんです
そこを覚えておけばすごく楽になるんですよ
人生は それで我々は知りたい
知りたいでしょ それで余計なことを知ってひどい目に遭う
人生不幸のどん底に陥れる
それでもう一つ出来事起こるんですよ
みんな知りたがり屋さんだから
情報を与える側が嘘をついて騙してやるそうとするんです
例えば 政府は国民のためやと言って
国民を見事にまんまと騙す
ということは どんな国でもよくやっています
国や組織や個人がよくやること
情報を隠すんですよ 情報を隠したら
こちらは間違ったものを知ったようにするんですよ
代わりに嘘を言って間違った知識を作る
マスコミでも堂々とやっているし
嘘を流す それで我々はバカだから
知りたいんだから これを鵜呑みにして
こういうことだ こういうことだとかね
嘘を言う側も楽に落ち着いていられない
例えば 国会で堂々と嘘を言ってね
楽じゃないんですよ 国が国民に対して
まああってもないことをね
隠したりして嘘だけ言うと
かなり厳しいんですよ
本人も なぜならば 何とかの方法で情報漏れたらどうしようかとかね
自分の首が飛んじゃうでしょうに
だから 各国の政府の人々は嘘を言うんだけど
自分の命がかけてますよ
だからでしょうね 命かけてやりますって言ってるのは
おそらく 嘘バレたら命がないんだからね
仕事はクビだからね 国のために命かけた政治家はね
現代時代では見たことはないんだけどね
国民の命をかけて自分に命を守ったことはいくらでもありますよ
例えば アメリカの大統領様がね
ブッシュさんがね アメリカの若者何千人も命犠牲にしてね
自分の立場が偉いと 俺はっていうね
あの戦争に出して それはあるんだけど
逆はないんです 言われた側も嘘が事実だと知って不幸になる
例えばイラクで WMD あるんだそうと
WMD って何でしたっけ？大量破壊兵器
ものすごい完璧な真っ赤な嘘
言う時でも知っていたんですけど
それが本当だと イギリス人もアメリカ人も日本人も鵜呑みにして信じ込んじゃって
どれぐらい死んじゃったんでしょうかね
日本人も何人か亡くなったし
それは亡くなったのは
それは軍隊工事じゃないんだけど
個人的なことだからね
それは置いておいても
日本の政府はどれぐらい金かかってるんですかね
今 一人当たり産まれる赤ちゃんでも 300 万でしたっけ？借金は
でしょ 一人当たりの借金は
ん？え  600 万だ 前の話か
古いんですね 私も これぐらい大変なのに
どれぐらいね 外国の活動に軍事費使いますかと
まあ日本のために使うのはね
それはまあどうにもならないことですからね
だからそれたった一個の噂の嘘のおかげでしょ
どうですかね 嘘の素晴らしさは
どれぐらい人死んでるんですかね
だから不幸になってない？嘘を信じて
それはわかりやすい例
日常の生活ではものすごいんですよ
皆様 痛くも痒くもないかもしれませんけど
軍事費たくさん行ってるんだそうとかね
ただ消費税上がったら文句を言うだけでね
それも大体 2 3ヶ月とかで終わっちゃうしね
まあそれは痛くも痒くもないと思ってるかもしれませんだけど
毎日ちょこちょこっと観察してください
嘘のせいでどれほど不幸になっているのかと
嘘は真実やと知ったことで
マスコミも利益のために
読者視聴者に刺激や喜びを与えるために情報をひねる
それに人が騙される 知りたがりっていうのは大変な問題ですよ
知りたがるから 世界は嘘の塊になっている
それを面白いというか矛盾というか
まあ勝手に判断してください
と 私は判断しません で
皆様方は知りたがり屋だから
世の中はどうなったかというと
嘘の塊になったんです
それほど知りたい知りたいとね
しつこく挑戦しなかったら
世の中は誰も嘘言わないよ
こんな不幸はないよ こんな苦しいことはなくなるんです
いろんな審査会やら調べるやら
あれ なんとか調査 なんとか調査
なんとか調査とか 全部なくなりますよ
この知りたがるんだから起きた問題なんです
この知りたがるものも
余計なことを知りたがるんだからなんですよ
学校に行って勉強することは全然問題ないんです
不幸になりません みんな応援する
しかし 学校の先生の裏の裏まで生徒たちが探そうと思っちゃうと
大変なことになります
余計なことまで知ろうとしちゃうと
先生に対していろいろあちこち噂をふらしちゃうと
もう学校ではいられなくなっちゃいますよ
だから余計な知りたがりは極端に危険
必要な知りたがりは何のことなく楽々幸福になる
だからもう知りたがるから嘘が現れたということは矛盾でしょう
知りたがるから知りた知れなくなっちゃったっていうのはおかしいでしょうに
知りたがるという病気と嘘を流すこと
それで世界は限りのない損しています
これ病気ですよ 知りたがるということは
仕事のために 収入のために
健康で生きるために知ることは病気じゃないんです
それはゴキブリにもありますからね
ミミズにもありますからね
病気じゃないんです それ以上言ったらもう病気です
それで世の中は嘘を流す
それはすごい損ばっかしで
限りない損 平和がなくなって戦争
争いにあふれる この世の中は平和がないし
争い 争い 争い 夫婦も喧嘩する
兄弟も喧嘩する もう会社でも喧嘩する
もうどこを見ても もうお互いにもう牙向き合ってるんですよ
人間は ゴキブリはないんです
ミミズも喧嘩しない 余計なこと知らないんだからね
隣にミミズがいたってもね
別にそれ知らないんですよ
ミミズは だから自分なりに平和できてるんです
しかし 我々は死ぬほど知りたいでしょう
どうしようもないんですよ
この病気は 知るということは私の命ですと
そこまで思っているんです
だから半分正しいんですよ
半分かな 一部は正しいんです
これ 半分じゃなくて もしかするともう 4分の1ぐらいかな
よく考えてください 皆様方は仕事に使う知識と持っている知識を比較してください
仕事にはほんのわずかな知識しか使わないんですよ
奥様方はね 家の家事にやら
そう 家を守るために使う知識と
新聞 雑誌 テレビで得る知識と比べてみてください
日中使っている知識というのはほんのわずかなんですよ
だから 3分の1ぐらいかな
ものすごい大目に計算しても
残りは苦しい 私自身ですね
私の知識は これはどういう意味でしょうかね
この私たちは 私 私とすごく胸を張って
自我を張って 高慢で もうむちゃくちゃやっているのは自分の知識なんですよ
お医者さんが自分勉強した医学が自分だと勘違いでえらく見栄を張る
弁護士は法律の知識は自分だと思って見栄を張ったりする
一般にすごい素朴な人間でなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから皆さんはお互いに挨拶するときはすぐ名刺を出して
私は何々者です なんとか課長
部長 あれやあれやこれやとかね
それで見た人が あんた課長様ですかね
あ それはそれは大変でと
うん これどうでもいいことなんですけど
付き合いは人間同士で起こるものなんですけど
だから結婚見舞い お見舞い
何でしたっけ？えっ？お見合いの時でも名刺でやっちゃうんだから
これで結婚したら最悪になるんだからね
肩書きで結婚したりするでしょ
人間と人間の結婚なんですけど
だからあなたはどんな料理好きかとかね
休みの時何やってるのかとかね
それぐらいで十分でしょうに
子供好きですかとかね
社長であろうが部長であろうが誰であろうかね
そこで平和な家族は築けますよ
それぐらいの知識で でも我々は自分と思っているのは
余計な知識を出して自我を張るんですよ
もう悪と言えばもう初めからも悪いんですよ
余計な知識得たことからも不幸なんですけど
この不幸の原因が自分だと出すと
もう大変なことなんです
それから知識は我々は小さい時から積み重なっていきますよ
例えばウサギちゃんだ
お花ちゃんだとかね 子供頃から知ることに挑戦する
一人でできたんだと また子供も自慢するでしょ
いや 皆様もそうでしょうに
結局はなんとか新しい余計なことを知って
あれは知ってるぞとかね
何かをやっても あれは私がやりましたよとかね
自慢したりして 同じですね
結局は でお利口さんだと褒めてもらうでしょう
子供だったら我々はどうですかね
何か仕事したらやっぱり褒めてほしいでしょ？認めてほしいでしょ
だからどこで大人になったんですかね
仏教から見れば 見ればね
人間っていうのは進化しないんですよ
そのまんま生まれた子供とそのまんまなんです
ただ気持ち悪くなっただけ
ちっちゃい時はかわいいでしょ
お人形さんみたいにむちゃくちゃかわいいしね
楽しいしね 子供が一人周りにいると
もういくらうるさくて走り回っても
はしゃいでもやっぱり楽しいんでしょうし
仕事するところに飛んできて邪魔しちゃってもね
全然どうったことはないんです
楽しいんだけど 我々はそれがなくなっただけ
ただ憎たらしくなっちゃって
醜くなっただけで 精神的には同じなんです
それで赤ちゃんと同じく
なんて楽しい 赤ちゃんも楽しいでしょう
人生は 今日も私はこちらに来る時に
ちょっと子供にやられちゃったんですけどね
まあ遅くなったんだから
まあちょこちょこと走ったような感じで
走り足で来たんですね
そこである小さな子供がいて
知ってる子供が一緒に走り出したんですよ
まあもうどうにも で もう途中で諦めて私は負けましたと
その子はもう行くところを知ってますからね
そこまで行って まあ勝ったんだからね
私の手を振って 手を振って
まあもう息も切られちゃって
ここまで来たんですけど
だから子供は楽しいんですよ
人生は それで我々もそうやってお利口さんだと言われて言われると楽しいんです
その楽しみを探してるんですよ
このように知るプロセスによって
自分 自我意識 自分のアイデンティティ
自分の存在感 生きている証
社会の中での自分 の立場
脳がなくなっています
生きる意義 目的が現れてくるんです
そのために死ぬほど知りたいんですよ
私たちのアイデンティティが私たちの知識なんです
おかしいんです 自分じゃないんです
知識あれば何か生きてる証になるんです
時々 あまり自分の知識で生きている実感がない場合は
趣味に凝っちゃうでしょ
特に男性はね 女性はあまり趣味がないんですけどね
趣味があったっても それでなんとか内職でも何かできるかないかとか考えちゃうんです
その方が一番理想ですけどね
男性は趣味として何かすごいごっついことに挑戦するでしょう
これですごく知識ないと
例えば最近まで おじい様たちはもう写真家になっちゃうんです
突然フォトグラファーになるんです
カメラ触ったこともないんだけど
小学生以外はね それでも六十五歳になったところで
いきなりフォトグラファーになったらできないんだから
無茶勉強するんですよ
むちゃくちゃ研究する
それですごい高価な機械買ったりして
いろんなところに行って
もう写真撮るわ撮るわ撮るわ撮るわ
もう何万枚でもね 何百枚でも撮る
見る人はいませんだけど
たまにいろいろ個展とかいろんなところ出す人もいるし
そうすると私も出さなくちゃということになったりもするし
で なんでそこまでかけるのかというと
それで生きているという実感が出てくるんですよ
仕事中はなかったんです
退職したところで やっぱり生きていたいという気持ちが出てきて
人間らしく 人間らしく生きるために知識に挑戦する
わかるでしょ？だから知識はアイデンティティになっているんです
生きる意義になっています
それから若者はやっぱり自分の社会の
自分の立場を確立するために知識に頼っちゃう
試験合格したり いろんな免許取ったり
いろんなあれこれやった卒業証明書をいろいろ集めたりするのは
この社会の立場を確立するためなんです
だから自我が知識になってますよ
だから知識はなかなか直せなくなっているんです
ですから死ぬほど知りたいんですよ
生きる意義ですからね
生きる意味もなくなっちゃいますから
何も知らないと 体に傷つけ
傷つけられても 知識を知を貶すのは絶対かな
絶対許せない なんとかって体に傷つけちゃってもね
傷つけてもね 全然あまりあまり気にしない
しかし 知識になんか言われちゃうと
もう我慢できない それが本当に傷つくんですよ
二人でなんかちょこっとしたことで
自分が相手の行為で もうちょっと体がちょこっと警戒してたならば
そんなにもう怒鳴ったり怒ったりすることはなく
ああ大変だ ああごめんとか何とか言って
それを手当てして それでだいたい終わりますよ
しかし 自分の知識にちょこっと一言言われると
もう大敵になっちゃうんですね
永久的に それが誹謗中傷ということになるんです
それが人権侵害にもするんです
知識けなしても人権侵害じゃないんだけど
そう思っちゃうんですよ
例えば アフガニアフガニスタンのある一人の人がキリスト教になったということで
今処刑に決めてます まだ決めてないんで
裁判中なんですけどね
イスラム人は宗教変わる変わるともう殺すと
いうことで それって人権侵害でしょ
人権侵害ないんだそうです
神を侮辱したんだと だから死ぬしかないんだと
西洋の圧力にかけて彼を解放しちゃおうと
国民に言いますよと グタクタ殺せと
彼らが あれほど肉体的な苦しみ
いろいろ受けているんだけど
それはそんなに問題にしないんですね
自分の知識に何か一言葉言われると
恐ろしく狂暴に立ち上がっちゃうんですよ
どうったことないんだ
ただのくだらない知識でしょうに
あれも余計な知識でしょ
その神を信じることで
人は死ぬわ死ぬわ 死ぬわ死ぬわ
キリがないと人は死ぬでしょうに
余計な知識いりませんよ
そんなこと何も信仰していない人はやっぱり気をつけて生きるんですよ
だからドーンと人を殺しに行くのは
本当に真面目に神を信じる人であって
真面目っていうのはちょっとまあもう間違ってますけどね
真面目に信じる人はそんなことやりませんだけど
あの あまり何も信仰しない人は
普通の常識を守ってね
これはやばいとよくないんだと
やらないんですよ だからあのケースの場合でも
この知識自体がおかしいんです
私が言いたがってるんですけど
もし場があったら書いて出しますけどね
キリスト教でも 何でしたっけ？絶対的な神を信じている
ユダヤ人も絶対的な神を信じている
イスラム人も絶対的な神を信じている
だから 名前はどうであろうとも
その人はただ神の名前を変えただけでしょう
アッラーの代わりにイエホワと言うだけでしょうに
神は一人しかいないんだったら
これってそんな大きな問題ですかね
だから その人と喧嘩するならば
あなたがた あなたの祈り方が間違っているんだよとかね
あなた誤解祈ってないでしょとかね
そういうこの人間のしきたりに対してゴチャゴチャ反論したっても別にいいんだけど
殺すそうって何だと あんた方はもう神が禁止している不浄な豚肉を食べてるでしょとかね
だからうちに来るなよとかね
まあそこまではそれも汚い知識なんですけど
そこまでは私はまあそこまでしょうがないと思いますけど
殺すっていうのは何なのかと
だから堂々と人権侵害でしょ
でも人権侵害だと思ってないんです
あの知識をちょこっとすることは大変な問題にするんですね
だから人間っていうのは
本当にもうもうもう知識は自分にしてるんですよ
知っていうことに命をかけてるんです
実際に 命かけるべきものかと
それは はい でも知る世界は残酷です
相手よりたくさん知りたくなく
知らなくてはならないでしょ
それ競争でしょ 知る世界で競争って後ろ来ないでしょ
子供たちも残酷でしょ
試験地獄と言っていたんだからね
今何言ってるかわかりませんだけど
相手の地に邪魔をしなくてはという
それもありますよ 情報ひねっちゃうんですね
だから残酷ですよ こちら
こちらは間違ったことを正しいと勘違いするんだからね
堂々と人を騙すんだから
もう残酷もいいところなんです
自分の知識を守らなくては
知識っていうのは あの余計な知識っていうのは
積み重ねても積み重ねても落ちるんですよ
忘れられるんです 必要な知識は落ちないんです
もう体に染まるんです
だからみんなこの知識が低下するとすごく心配するでしょ
低下するのは余計な知識なんです
学校で英語を勉強したでしょ
今はさっぱりでしょ あれはもういらないんだからなくなってるんです
でも年取っても年取っても日本語は忘れないでしょ
ボケても日本語できるでしょ
面白いでしょ あの ボケるっていうのは失礼な単語ですけど
そういうアルツハイマーとかね
そういう病気になっても言葉はわかってますね
だから必要なものは落ちません
だから我々は余計な知識って
それを守るためにずっと頑張らなくちゃいけない
大変苦しいんですよ 知る能力を伸ばさなくては
それでいくら何でも人々には何でも知ることできるんだから
まあ疲れてこれ以上はできないというふうに
この悲観的になったりもしますよ
その時 もっともっと能力を伸ばさなくちゃ
能力を伸ばさなくちゃとまた苦労するんですよ
これは大変苦しいんですよ
数学できない人は数学合格しようと思うとすごく苦しいんですよ
自分の知識を認めてもらわなくてはということがあるんですね
知っただけではたまりません
だからね 発表しなくちゃ
本書かなくちゃとかいろいろ出てくるんです
ということは 社会から認めてもらわなくちゃっていうね
社会に依存する それまた残酷ですよ
これは安全確保なんですけど
でもやっぱり大変です
などの課題があるんです
無知では生きる権利 資格がなくなるから
知に命をかけなくてはならない
人間というのは大変な運命ですよ
無知だったらもうこの世の中では
もう生きていられない
苦しい社会 我々はわざと作ったんです
基本的な知識だけで十分なんですけど
わざと作ったんです だからもうしょうがない
もう知らなきゃ もう生きる権利も最後なくなっちゃうんです
それから知ることの副作用
落ち込んだり 自信がなくなったりする
あれも副作用ですよ 例えば
いろんなことを知ると
もうそれで考えて考えて落ち込んだりする
あの人 私に何か変 嫌なことを言ったんじゃないかなとかね
私は足を引っ張らせてるんじゃないかなとかね
私の能力をね 嫉妬しているんじゃないかなとか
それ知る世界から出てくる考え方でしょ
それで落ち込むんですよ
悩んだりするんですよ
自信もなくなったりする
仕事の世界でも 隣の人の仕事を早く終わっちゃうと
あ 俺は才能ないなとかね
それで自信がなくなっちゃうんです
引きこもるになったり
自殺までしたりする 結構自殺するんですよ
傲慢になったり 他人を差別
軽視したりする 知識のせいでしょ
傲慢になる 軽蔑する 差別する
人間関係はうまくいかなくいかなかったりする
知る世界のせいで 性格が他人と変わるから孤独になったりする
これを覚えておいてください
自分が知る世界は自分だけの世界なんですよ
隣のお友達は 知っている世界は彼の世界なんですよ
結局 友達関係あっても
家族で一緒にいたっても
みんな孤独なんです 心でつなげてすごく気持ちよくいられないんですよ
孤独になっちゃうんです
平等がなくなったりする
例えば人間なら平等でしょ
世界でないんだから そんなのは
微妙にでも平等はないんです
それは知る世界のせいなんです
社会に溶け込めなかったりする
あまりにも知りすぎちゃうと溶け込めなくなるでしょ
これはすべて副作用なんです
生きる目的の知は生きることの障害になる
結局 なんで知りたかったというと
生きるためなんですけど
この知は障害になるんです
次のページに行きます
知る世界っていうのはゴールのないマラソンですよ
死んじゃいますよ マラソン走ると
ゴールまで走りそうと走ったら
ゴールがなかったらどうなるんですかね？死ぬでしょ
渇愛と似たような働きになります
知るということは渇愛と似ています
仏教のいう渇愛 渇愛っていうのは
あってもあってももっと欲しいということなんです
満たせない気持ちに渇愛というんです
渇愛わからないんだったら
この考えてください お金がいくらあったらよろしいですかね
リミットないでしょ お金ならいくらでもという
それが渇愛なんです 美しく
例えば神様が来て 君に希望を １個かな
希望を一つ叶えてあげますよと
それであるいは美しくなりたいと言ったら
神様が自分に希望を叶えてくれるならば
どこまで美しくなったら気が済む？きりがないんですよ
だからそれ渇愛の世界で
知ることも いくら知ってももっと知りたくなります
しかし 疲れるから苦しいから
途中で知ることを諦めて衰退するのは普通です
みんな若い時ね もう何でも知りたがるんだけど
どんどんこれやめちゃやめるんですよ
なぜならばもう疲れますよ
知れば知れば知るほど
やめたところから衰退するんですよ
結局 どうこう言っても結果は同じなんです
知識が年とともに衰えます
いくら何でも年とともに衰えます
しかし 知りたいという欲だけは続くんですよ
だから私も結構衰えているんだから
この講演の内容もあまり信頼できないと思いますけど
まあ知りたいという欲だけはなかなか衰えませんね
だからそれはゴールのないマラソンですよ
それで終わらないんですよ
人間は一切智者へ挑戦するんです
本当はゴールはそれなんです
すべて知りたがるの すべて知ってるんだったらかっこいいだなとかね
思っちゃうんです 哀れなほど短い寿命なのに
一切を知りたがる 寿命は短いんですよ
憐れみなんです ほんのすごい短い
宇宙を知り尽くしたがるでしょ
できることかと そんなのは
宇宙の始まり終わりを知りたがる
馬鹿は頑張ってますけど
皆様はどうかわかりませんだけどね
かなり研究してますよ
宇宙に人間と同じ生命がいるか否かを知りたいんですね
そのために膨大な財産を浪費する
成功すると何人かが調子に乗るが
世界は経済不調 貧困 ガシで病んでいるんです
いかにアホらしことは覚えておいてください
何兆円のお金かけて なんかちょこっとした機械を空に飛ばしちゃって
それでもう何ヶ月とか
一年二年間 それはもう遠隔操作あれで操作して
写真ぐらい撮って 写真一枚来るためにも三週間かかるわ
それでなんとかやったそう
成功したぞと調子に乗ってます
何人かが 何兆万円のお金使って
しかし人類はどうでしょうかというと
貧困 餓死 これで頭いいと言えますかね
それで次にやるのは このこと
妄想や観念の世界に突入する
だから一切知りたいでしょ
宇宙の始まりから終わりまで知りたいしね
これできんでしょ それで妄想を始めるんです
科学のね そういう宇宙科学はなんとかなんとか
それはだいたい 8 割以上妄想ですよ
本当のことじゃないんです
自分が早く死ぬから一切を知れないんですよ
これわかった人はからくりするんです
永遠不滅の人なら一切を知ってるでしょうと思うんです
もし誰かが永遠不滅の人がいるんだったらね
その人は知ってるんですよ
すべてはね 当たり前ですからね
妄想なんです 自分が一切知りたいというくだらん欲を持ってるんだから
もしいたらどうかなと
あのギリシア神話あるでしょ
あれすごいかわいいんですよ
人間に満たせない欲望を神話で満たしてもらう
だからそれ以上言ってないんだから
私はかっこいいと思ってます
例えば 戦争にて戦いたいでしょうね
もう敵だったら誰でも倒したいって
もう人間無理でしょ そこで戦いのギリシアの神様がいるでしょ
何でしたっけ？名前忘れちゃった
誰でしたっけ？まあ えっ？マルマルマルス
うん で 美しさだったらね
どんな人間の女性見たってもね
どこか何か気に入らないポイントはありますよ
本人はあまり気づいてないんですけど
男たちは知ってます だから
まああれを男 まあほとんど男たち作った物語だよ
男たちは完璧な女性を作るんですよ
人間では見つからないんだから
ビーナスという神様にするんです
それで男性の場合も同じだから
完璧な男性って何でしたっけ？誰でしたっけ？イーロス
キューピッド イーロスかな
という神がいるんです
すごいかっこいい男なんです
完璧 このエロティックとかね
そういう単語もその神様の名前なんですよ
あれ 日本語でエロと言うんでしたっけね
性的な関係のことでね
だからギリシアの神様はイーロスなんですね
そこまでは別にもうかわいいんですよ
もうバレバレだからね
気持ちは でもそれから時代的にもう絶対神を作っちゃったんです
あれは人間のまた妄想の結果で
同じプロセスですよ どうせ人間だからね
考えるのは それでこの自分が一切知りたいんだけど
もう知れないし 死んじゃうし
だから誰かがいるでしょうと
すべて永遠不滅の人がね
その人なら全部知ってるんだと
その永遠不滅の人と組めば
2つの得がある 永遠不滅の誰かいると思ったんですけど
いるかどうか調べてまだないんです
すぐに結論に行くんですよ
すごい早い欲がありすぎ
では組めば得が 2つです
1自分も永遠になる これでよかったでしょうね
死ぬんだから 人間なら
2今まで知らなかったことも知ることができる
万々歳 人間のもう無限に知りたい欲がそこで終了するという風に
これ観念妄想を作るんですよ
いるか否か 否かを後回しにして
人間はね では その人と一緒になる方法は何でしょうかと次に考えるんです
それ考える前に 絶対的生命がいるか否かと調べなくちゃあかんだけど
それは後回しにして どうすればこの絶対的人物と一緒になるのかということは
人類 世界のすべての人類をすぐに考えたんです
中国人は中国人なりに
その文化に合わせて インド人はインド人の文化に合わせて
ペルシア人は今イランですけど
そちらに合わせて エジプトとユダヤ人はそちらに合わせたもの
ギリシア エジプト人は自分なりにあっちこっちでもこの偉いヤツと一緒になる方法を考えるんです
では さらに妄想しましょうということになるんです
これ妄想だからね それで預言者が出現するんです
これって人間作ったからくりだと思いますけどね
こういう考え方あると
ある人がこそっと私は預言者だよと言っちゃうと立場がいいんですよ
だって誰も知らないんだから
この絶対的な人のことを
預言者がいると言ってくれたら
まあもうみんなそちらにも勢いでしがみつくんです
身の回りのことしか知らない一般人により
上手を取って また知りたがる大衆を自分で支配する目的で
預言者という手段があるんです
皆さんは預言者になったら結構儲かりますよ
みんなもうさっと寄ってきます
食いかかってきます 何言ったっても大丈夫です
誰も調べません 大丈夫です
安全です 預言者が預言する
それで我々は意図なく信じる
そして預言にケチをつける理性ある人々を弾圧する
もう世界で起きていますからね
預言者があの永遠不滅の存在
存在の声 言葉を聞く また会って預言をいただくという権威を取るんです
私は神の声を聞いてます
神の言葉をいただいてますとかね
それでそれを権威ですね
将来のこと 我々が行うべき生き方
人類の最後 死後のことを教えてくれますね
ご預言者は 残念なことに
預言 預言は理解しにくい
なんであれは 預言っていうのを面白くわからないんですよ
神がほか 預言者ほかわからないんですけどね
明確に言えばいいでしょう
何年何月何日 なんとかとかね
だからみんな預言というのは勝手に解釈するんですよ
イスラム教にしたっても
コーランという預言書があるんだけど
それ勝手に解釈するんだから
宗派が出てきてむちゃくちゃ殺し合ってるんです
だからあれこれといつでも勝手に解釈
有限の知識能力の人間に無限な知識能力者の意図はわかる
でしょうと見事に納得までする
それで解釈して解釈してうまくいかない場合は納得するんです
わかるわけないでしょ
預言は 聖書はと 聖書というのはキリスト教の本だけではなくて
そういう預言書を全部
神様には無限の知識があって
我々のは愚直とした知識がないんだからわからない
それで見事に納得するんです
神しか知らないんだと
はい それからブッダの時代に入りましょう
休憩したいんだけど またまたたくさんありますので
えーと これが今までのところで
皆様方はね あまり批判的で気持ち悪いと思ったかもしれません
だけど 皆様知らないブッダの世界に入ったらね
大丈夫だと思います ブッダの時代でも問題は同じ
人間いるならば問題は同じですよ
今の現代人間だけ馬鹿じゃないんです
どちらでもどんな時代でも同じですよ
あまり だからまあ バラモン教の人々は 10
人の仙人たちの預言に固まったんです
お釈迦様の時代であったヒンドゥー
現代ヒンドゥー教は当時でのバラモン教と呼ぶんです
ヒンドゥー教まで発展してなかったんです
バラモンカーストの人々の宗教でした
それで彼らは 10人の仙人が神の言葉を我々に教えてくれたというんです
ヴェーダ聖典はその言葉だそうです
バラモン教の聖典はヴェーダ聖典で言うんです
4つあります かなり大きいんです
普通に読んでみると ただの歌なんですよ
普通の作品なんです 詩なんです
昔のかつての詩人たちは立派な詩を作ったんです
詩だからもうシンボルあるわ
もうわからないことあるわ
いろいろ それが神の言葉にしちゃったんだからね
そこで釈尊はバラモン知識人に聞く
こういう風に ビシッと聞きます
あのアッタコ ワーマコ
ワーマデーヴォ ウェッサーミット
ヤマタッギー アンギーラソ
バーラッドワージョ ワーセット
カッサポ バグ それの 10人の名前なんです
仙人なんです という仙人たちは
ヴェーダ聖典は私たちが直接経験して知っている
間違いありませんと保証をつけて言っているのでしょうかと聞くんです
これ お釈迦様はヴェーダ聖典はもうものすごく子供頃ずっと勉強なさったんです
王様 王子様でいた時は暗記です
昔は本ないんだからね
だから業丹下で知ってるんだから
どこにも書いてないんです
ただの詩なんです ではみんなで火を称え称えましょうと
と 火そのものを称えて歌うんですよ
それは火はありがたいんだから
称えるのは悪くないし
では雨を称えましょうと
それでバラモン人が勘違いして
火の神様 雨の神様 風の神様
雷の神様という風に 風神何人何人とかね
神にするんです でお釈迦様はヴェーダ聖典知ってるんだから
これただの火を称えている歌だよと
作品だから悪くもないしね
だから聞くんですよ この作者たちが
これ我々は経験して 直接知ってなんじらに言ってますよと
保証ありますかと聞いたところで
バラモンたちは堂々と
みんな知識人ですよ だから嘘言わない
ただのバラモンには聞かないんです
トップクラスの知識人のバラモンに聞くんです
言うとトップクラスだからね
そういう言葉がないんだと言うんです
戦地者の告げということで
はい それで 聖書について今これから喋ります
そこで世界で古い聖書といえばヴェーダ聖典
アヴェスタという本はヴェーダ聖典よりちょこっと古いんだけど
あの旧約聖書は古いとは言い難いんですよ
もうずっと時代的にもう進んできたんだから
キリスト様まで だから旧約聖書はすごく古い
一番古いというのは私は正しくないと思います
はっきりした歴史はないんです
ジェネシスという本はまあ後で書いたもんでしょう
もう最後まで書いてますからね
最後って言ったって イエス様のところまでジェネシス書いてますから
しかし このアヴェスタとかね
ヴェーダ聖典というのは立期した古いんですよ
後で足したものはないんです
昔ももうコンパクトになって本になっていたんです
そのヴェーダ聖典は本当は怪しいということなんです
お釈迦様の立場から見れば
我々に言ってくれた人々は胡椒すぎてないんです
反抗してないんです これは神の直接な言葉であると
そこでブッダの時代で
聖書のような高次元の先知
洗脳者の言葉を信仰する宗教集団はアヌッサビカという名前で知られているんです
アヌッサビカって これはお釈迦様がつけた名前です
なぜならば 皆様はパーリ仏教を勉強しても
私が言っているようなものは見つからないんです
こんなことあるのかと
これはこの日本訳の問題と
まあ当時の時代のことをね
時代背景で理解しないとね
出てこないんです だから聖書という言葉を使わないんですよ
お釈迦様がアヌッサビカという単語を使うんです
アヌッサビカの意味はお伝えを信じて伝えるということなんです
こちら人を意味しますけど
お伝えはアヌッサと言うんです
だから聖書って意味なんです
仏教では以下のように評価するんです
このアヌッサのこと サンダカよ
これは経典から取ったもので
この世でアヌッサビカ真言を信じる人々
神の言葉が真理 事実 アヌッサヴァサッチョだと認める
認めるカイス様たちがいる
日本語的にちょこっとコンパクトがないんだけど
そう書かないと文章長くなるんです
これ お釈迦様の言葉をそのまま引用するんです
この世で神の言葉を事実真理だと信じているカイス様たちがいる
だからこの人を信仰しちゃうんだから
後でね 彼らは言い伝えに沿って
聖典に頼って説法する
しかし 聞いた話 いわゆる伝えを真理の証拠として語る場合はね
ということで 正しく聞いたかも
聞き間違いあったかも
真理は聞いた通りになるかも
違った通りになるかもよと
この初めて聞いた人は聞き違いしたらどうしますかね
かもしれません ということは
証拠不十分ということです
真理という保証はないという理由
お釈迦様ははっきり言うんで
たとえを聖典 にあっても真理にはならないと
証拠 100%の証拠はないんだよと
間違って間違う可能性はすごくあるんだよと
そこで理性のある人は満足できない教えだと立ち去る
聖書を持って説法すると
聞く人に理性があれば
これは満足できんと もしかすると違うかも
もしかすると本物かも
五分五分満足できんと立ち去るんだよと
これはこういうサンダクすったという経典から引用したんです
だから直接聞いても無駄ですよ
あの永遠不滅の人から直接聞いても
聞き違えてたらどうするんですかね？あるいは変に理解していたら
どうせ皆様そうでしょう
我々何言っても自分なりに理解するでしょ
昔から今まで世界の人口の 90%ほどが神の霊言を宗教として信じているが
証拠不十分 実証できない
五分五分の賭けという問題はついてくるんです
これ五分五分の賭けなんですよ
危ないんです また 聖書はたくさんあるから
どちらが正しいか 本当に真面目に聞いたのかという疑問もあるんですよ
あんた方 本当に真面目に聞いたのよと
だって聖書いくつあるでしょ？コーランとウェード聖典というのはまるっきり違うんですよ
コーランと聖書はまるっきり違うんですよ
新約聖書は 本当に聞いたのかと聞きたいんですよ
宗教宗派によって解釈は変わるから
本当にわかっているのかよというね
誤解しているのかという問題もありますよ
だって神の言葉なのに
なんで解説だけはもう 103 ものすごくあるんですかね
例えばキリスト教の場合は
聖書っていうのはこうやって手で取れるでしょ
聖書について書いている本の数々
すごい量ですよ ローマ教会のね
ある図書館なんか来たってもね
もう すごい量だそうですよ
資料やら だからなんでそんなにいろいろ意訳というか
意訳じゃない いろんな解説できますかね
元の言葉が曖昧だからでしょ
あるいは真面目に聞いてないか
わかってないか どちらかなんですね
だから直接聞いてもダメですよ
不安を呼ぶ知識欲 すべてを知りたがって
人間がそれは無理だと諦めたところで
先知者の観念が出現しました
そこで全知先知 洗脳者の観念がそのような言われで出現したんです
これは仏教的な解説なんです
預言者も現れた しかし
先知者の言葉だというものから
一切を知ることは不可能でした
それでもできないんだからね
だって聖書によって地球が平らだよと言い張っていたしね
別に聖書では平らとも何も言ってないんですけど
なんでそんな変な解説するんですかね
しかし 宇宙はたくさんあるんだぞと書いてないでしょ
仏典には書いてますよ
宇宙は無限にものすごいんだよと
なんで聖書どちらでもないんですかね
私の国ですごい昔 アメリカ人が月に行ったでしょ
それで私の国のイスラムのある人々はね
言って これはありえない
これは神様だよと 天だよと
嘘を言うんだと あのもうインフィニティ
もう悪魔の連中はと 絶対見てませんと
ものすごい頑固に挑戦してたんです
まあまあ 我々田舎どうし
田舎でもそういう同士で喋りますからね
だから全然問題にならなかったんですけど
ありえませんよと堂々と言うんですね
それで私が でもなんか写真とか出ていますけど
そんなのはいくらでも作れるでしょうに
どこかにいて写真撮れば
あんたよくもそんなことをいちき信じるもんだなとかね
私にまで怒るんです 本人にとっては隙を見てお祈りするんだから
これはありえないということにになるんですね
ということは 聖書に頼っても戦地者にはなりませんということです
それより自説は真理で
他説は邪視だと 戦う争うことになっただけです
聖書から出たら結果は何やというと
私が言うことを正しくて
あなた方が言うことは間違っているというふうに
人類はお互いに争うことになっただけ
結果は ブッダの ちょっと 30 秒ぐらい休みます
皆さんも頭を休めて休ませてください
30 秒ですよ 決めたら決める
ああ どうぞどうぞ まあこれからのまあ
全くテーマを変えて 別なところに行きますので
はい では始まります これで
あの 神の言葉に頼るんじゃなくて
自分で調べるぞという勇気のある人々が出たんですよ
預言者の話の受け売りで知ることにしないで
自分で戦地に挑戦する人もいたんです
自分で挑戦するのはどうですかと
長部経典のナンバー１のナンバーワンというのはベストという意味じゃなくて
番号の番です 今日は自分の力で知ることに挑戦した方々の結論を集約したようなものです
あれはすごく難しい経典ですけど
すごく長いし ブッダの時代で自分で挑戦した人
戦地戦地にこの努力と内容を集約しています
62 の宗教的訂正教説があります
その経典に 62 種類にカテゴリーしています
それもお釈迦様が 62 にコンパクトにしたんだけど
インドではやっている人々の場合はそこほど明確な分析はないんですけど
一部の師匠か以外 皆知識能力を開発し
五感の次元を超えて観察したんです
一部はただ頭を使って理屈で世界はあれや
生命はこれやとか言ったんだけど
これ一部あまり通ったことないんで
論理だからね でもたくさんの人々はそうじゃなくて
我々よりはるかに知識次元を超えちゃって
いわゆる現代風に言えばすごく超能力を得て
一生懸命瞑想して 知識次元を破って超越した知識能力を得て
それで観察したんです
だからかなりすごいんです
そこで超の2 能力超エスサたちの話ではこうなるんです
過去を観察して達した師匠は十八あります
将来に関する師匠は四十四あります
それで全部まとめたら六十二になります
彼らの能力範囲のスケールは巨大でした
今日は時間ないんだから
ちょこちょこと 中身は面白いんですよ
私が説明すると 皆様はテキストを直接読んでも
もう超面白くないとわからないと思いますけどね
このセクションでは 私はかなり若い時からかなり腕が上がっていたんです
大学でもね 自分が先生たちいるのに自分が権威になっていたんです
宇宙と生命の過去を広範囲で広範囲で見たんです
過去を見るんだったら
もう一年 十年 百年の過去じゃないんです
広範囲で見たんです こうパーリ語でカッパと言うんですよ
の意味は 私の主観でいう
これ私の主観で言えば
宇宙一つ現れて消えてゆく時間ですが
個っていうのは宇宙一つ現れてまた消えてゆく
その時間は一で数えるんです
一個 宇宙とは 全宇宙か銀河系一つか
ソーラーシステム太陽系一つかはよくわからない
ただ宇宙中というだけで
まあ一応宇宙っていうのは宇宙一個現れてきて
どんどん広げていって
また収縮してなくなる
それで一 一番長く過去を観察した人はチャッターリーサンピサンガッタヴィワッターニと経典で書いていますよ
四重膨張収縮まで遡ったんですよ
科学的に信じられますかね
科学者には一個もわからないんですよ
あの瞑想した あのブッダの時代で
ちょこっと前にいた修行者たちが
一番能力ある人は四重まで遡ったんですよ
そこで宇宙は収縮するし
膨張するということは
ブッダの時代 ブッダはね
仏教ではもうただのごく一般的な話なんです
面白い びっくりってじゃないんです
ごく当たり前で書くんです
それで一個といえば だから収縮は一個で数える場合もあるし
膨張も一個で数える場合もあるし
収縮膨張セット一個に数える場合もあるし
そこら辺はそれほど定かじゃないんですけどね
でも四重といえばね 四重こう見たといえば
もう冗談じゃないんですよ
過去 あの これは仏教以外の人々の瞑想の能力は四重で切れちゃうんです
お釈迦様はもういくらでも見られます
過去 お釈迦様のいろんな話は四重ではなくて
もっともっとすごく遡って過去のことを取り出して
昔こうなったよと言うんです
だから時間的に見れば
いつでも人間世界が現れるわけじゃないんですよ
し だからもう大変だと思いますよ
過去を見ても見ても 宇宙があって
物質的に宇宙が出たってもね
生命の誕生はまたゆっくりのんびりでしょうし
だからそれをずっとたどっていかなくちゃいけない
そこで宇宙が消えちゃうと
我々人間の生命っていうのは別な次元に行くんですよ
もう体持てない次元とかね
そういうところを全部チェックしていかなくちゃいけないんだから
できる能力じゃないんですよ
いくら考えても 宇宙が収縮して空になって
それから徐々に世界と生命が現れてくる過程を
回数四重まで直接見て達した結論で
結論であっても ブッダは不完全な結論だとするんです
だからブッダのスケールわかりますかね
我々は現代科学的に見ても
ビッグバンというのはもう計算して
それからいろいろデータを取ったところであっただろうという推測で
まあ時間もなんとなくわかっているだけで
でも見事に知ることはできないしね
だから こちらは四重まで見ているんだからね
それでもブッダがね それでもあなた方の宗教哲学は不完全だよと
一つの例で考えてみましょう
また経典の引用なんですけど
比丘たちよ この世は収縮する時があります
その時 ほとんどの生命はアーヴァッサラというところに生まれます
心のみで合成される生命は
喜悦を味わいながら喜びを栄養にして長い時間過ごすと
それ過去を見るとそういうことを見えます
宇宙がこれ膨張して収縮する時の話で
収縮縮んじゃっちゃうと物質が小さくなるんです
ものすごい硬くなるんですね
そこで潰れますけど 生命にはいられなくなるんです
それで生命は心が飛んでいくんです
飛んだら物質ない次元に行くんです
それをアーヴァッサラという名前に名前で言ってるんです
物質と何の関係もない
素粒子一向にも関係ない次元に飛びます
そちらではもう体ないんだからね
素粒子一本物質ないんだからね
で 大変喜びだけ感じる
ものすごい幸福を感じて
栄養になるのは喜びなんです
だからもう喜んで喜んでいるだけで
もうむっちゃ長い時間いるんです
また その世は この世は膨張を始める
だから シューってなった小さくなった宇宙がどんどん膨らんでいく
その時 誰もいない空きの梵天界に梵天界一つが現れます
そちらに一人の生命がアーヴァッサラから降りて生まれます
そこで宇宙が膨張していくと
まだまだ太陽などなどはできてないかもしれませんだけど
えーと 天界は先に次元的に現れると
なので一番先に梵天が現れてからですね
スペースができるだけ膨張するんだから
スペースが現れるんですね
そちらにアーヴァッサラというところにいた誰かが
寿命を尽きたか もう徳が消えたか
どちらかの原因で生まれるんです
その時は微妙な体があるんです
初めて 初めて自分で実感できる体が出ます
しかし 我々みたいな細胞とかあれはないんですけど
硬いもの何もないんですけど
まあもしかすると素粒子ぐらいかも
その生命は気が長くなるほどの時間
そちらに過ごす これ 経典ではこれをすごいすごいすごい長い長い長い時間
この神があちらにいるんだと
だって太陽一つでもね
すごい時間でしょ 地球にでもね
地球が現れて 生命誕生まですごい時間かかったでしょうね
退屈になった彼が それ長い長い時間一人で退屈になるんですよ
他の生命もいた方が良いという思うようになるんです
自分にはなんとなく微妙なこと
神の霊的な体があるんだからね
私一人だけね もう誰か誰かいたってもと
それでまた長い長い時間経つんですよ
長い長い時間経つと 彼は長い長い時間この希望でいるんです
そうするとまたアーヴァシルの生命たちが
やっぱり寿命は終わっちゃうわ
徳が終わっちゃうわ それで次から次へとこの梵天に落ちるんです
落ちたら体が微妙に霊の体が現れるんです
全く体がなかったんだからね
それで何とかざらざらっと煙のような体が現れちゃう
先に生まれた梵天は寿命も力も輝きも誰よりも増している
彼がこのように思う どうも今回はね
これはもう これは一回見たらケースであって
この四十回 八十回見ると必ずそういうふうになるというわけじゃないんだけど
まあ今回お釈迦様見た会では
やっぱりこの先に生まれた人がね
かなり力があって 影響力というか
もう何て言いますか オーラがあって
寿命すごく長い 彼がこういうことを思うんですよ
私が他の生命がいた方が良いと思い続けた
それでその生命が生まれてきた
私が他の生命を創造したでしょう
私が主 生命の親分であろうと
私が現れて欲しかった
で現れた だから私は欲しいと思ったら現れるんだから
俺が作ったんだ 文句あるのかと
俺が作ったもんだから
俺がもう父親で もう親分だと
と思うんですね そこでお釈迦様は
この絶対的な神様の概念はえらくからかっているでしょう
だから私はそれを派手にわかりやすくからかうんだからね
もうすごい質素な単語ばっかりやと思ってるかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様はもっと品がいいんだからね
微妙に笑っちゃうんです
あんた勘違いだよと 後に生まれた生命も
この人は我々より先にここにいました
この人は我々を創造したであろう
我々の主 親分であろうと思う
後から来たってもね 先輩がいるんだから先輩偉いでしょうに
それでまあ その人に尊敬することになっちゃうんです
これは勘違い また時間が経つと人間界が現れてきますね
それでまた何万年 何百万年とか
時間経って経って経っていくと
じわじわと物質的な地球も宇宙も現れてきて
人間界が現れてくる 後に生まれた梵天の寿命が終わったものは人間界に生まれる
その中でもたくさんいるんだから
一人の梵天がなんか自分の寿命が切れちゃって亡くなるんです
亡くなったらもう人間界あるんだからね
そちらにさらに落ちるんです
だから上でいて徳が済んだら下に来るしかないんです
徳がないんだから もっと上行きなさいとは言わないんですよ
ビジネスホテルのあれ
お金払えない人をあなた
あの寮亭なんとかに泊まりなさいとは言えませんだからね
もっと払えないんだからね
だったらもう公園のベンチで寝なさいということになるんで
やっぱり下行くんです
しかし そういう人々は
この梵天にいたんだから
人間みたいだらしないことはあまりやりたがらない
梵天にいる場合は欲がないんですよ
性欲もないし 怒りもないし
心きれいし だから人間になっても癖がついちゃって
やっぱり修行するんだよと
修行に励むんですよ それで人は修行に励んで励んで
禅定を過ごして過去を見る力を得る
彼が自分の過去を観察して
このように説く 本人が瞑想して
私は過去どこにいたのかと見るんです
そうすると見える 見えたらこういうふうなことを言うんです
梵天にいる大父創造主が洗脳で不死です
彼に創造された我々が死に至るのです
永遠ではありませんと
と説法するんです 嘘を言ってるわけじゃないんです
勘違いだけ 本人は経験で喋ってはいるんだけど
どうか仏教から見れば
ちょっと待ってよ もっと観察しなさいということなんですよ
このように超越した知識
能力で過去の事実は経験して知っているが
不完全な結論に立ってしまうんです
だからダメとも言えないし
間違っているとも言えないし
真面目に修行もしているんだから経験は正しいしね
でも結論は曖昧 では ここら辺で休憩いたします
なんとか出てこないな
あ 出ました  はい